[Musique]
cherch demain matin c'est que tu passer
pour
contl mais
j pour père
noëlore comme dansours de de
noëlous pourver
maisaintenël ma
préér
[Musique]
oh non vous êtes où regardezv dans un
miroiroi quo vous ressemblez
Miro je ressemble un prisonnier non
clochardabru c'est moi mon dans vre
cette famille etrver t monde il faut
surtout pas que H et Armando
CELI qui ve baiser votre
femme
age vous l'avez envoyé où
l'autre bonjour t
sport il me demande de cuisiner
carrément vous êtes chef custo on a déjà
la farine gagner un maximum de temps
cuisinez ce qui vous demande ne vous
faites pas remarquer ne parlez pas le
thème c'est sortie d'école familiale
qu'est-ce que c'est que cette merde
pardon swing vous m'avez utilisé pour
cuisiner de la drogue
la personne
g tu crois que tu me fais
peur ça cass les
[Musique]
couilles je crois que c'est le moment de
rentrer dans la
danse mal tu retournes au courrier en
[Musique]
bant